♪ ♪
>> Dana: JOE BIDEN HAVE BEEN
DOING FAIRLY WELL IN MANY POLLS
BUT IS HE TO COMPLEMENT
CAMPAIGNING FROM HIS BASEMENT?
THE PRESUMPTIVE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE MAKING ANOTHER GAFFE BY
MIXING OF JOBS DATA WITH
CORONAVIRUS DEATHS.
>> WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC THAT COST US MORE THAN
85,000 JOBS AS OF TODAY.
LIVES, BILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
MILLIONS OF JOBS.
>> Dana: BIDEN RAISING SOME
EYEBROWS WITH WHAT HE WAS SAYING
TO POTENTIAL VOTERS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TARA READE ALLEGATION.
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD VOTE
THEIR HEART TO THAT THEY
BELIEVED TARA READE, THEY
PROBABLY SHOULDN’T VOTE FOR ME.
I WOULDN’T VOTE FOR ME IF I
BELIEVED TARA READE TARA READE.
THE FACT IS, LOOK AT TERRY
REED’S STORY, CHANGES
CONSIDERABLY.
-- TARA READE’S STORY.
>> Dana: KENNEDY, THE
DEMOCRATS, IF YOU REMEMBER
DURING THE KAVANAUGH HEARINGS
AND THE ME TOO MOVEMENT WHEN IT
WAS AT ITS HEIGHT, THE MANTRA
WAS TO BELIEVE ALL WOMEN.
NOW JOE BIDEN IS BASICALLY
SAYING IF YOU BELIEVE HER, DON’T
VOTE FOR ME.
IT’S NOT SHOWING THAT HE’S NOT
GOING TO ANSWER IN ANY OTHER
WAY?
HE IS SAYING THIS ABSOLUTELY DID
NOT HAPPEN?
HE IS NOT CRACKING ON ANY OF
THAT.
>> Kennedy: HE WAS SAYING HE
DOESN’T BELIEVE HER THEREFORE
SHE MUST BELONG THEN I WISH
SOMEONE WOULD POSE THAT QUESTION
TO HIM.
DO YOU THINK TARA READE IS
LYING?
BECAUSE WHAT HE’S DOING HERE IS
ESSENTIALLY VICTIM SHAMING.
IT’S A GROSS PERVERSION OF THE
MUTUALLY ACCEPTED RULES OF ME
TOO, PARTICULARLY WHEN THEY WERE
APPLIED TO THE KAVANAUGH
HEARINGS.
I DON’T THINK HE HAS ANSWERED
THIS VERY WELL.
AS FAR AS JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGNING
FROM HIS BASEMENT I THINK HE’S
USING A CORONAVIRUS TO GET OUT
OF THE BAIT IN THE DEBATES ARE
GOING TO BE CRITICAL.
WE HAVE TO SEE SPONTANEOUS
MOMENTS TO MAKE SURE THE PERSON
IS GOING TO LEAD THE FREE WORLD
CAN DO SO AND RESPOND TO BULBS
AND INTELLECTUAL CHALLENGES.
SO FAR, JOE BIDEN HAS REALLY
BEEN PROTECTED FROM THAT.
>> Dana: AND HE’S DOING THESE
INTERVIEWS PRETTY MUCH WITH
FAIRLY FRIENDLY REPORTERS, GREG.
HE HAS THAT GAFFE, THE MESS UP
AT THE BEGINNING, MIXING UP THE
DEATHS VERSUS THE JOBS NUMBERS.
I’M NOT SURE HOW HE GETS BETTER
AT ANY OF THIS BEFORE HE WOULD
HAVE TO FACE PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
A DEBATE BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> Greg: THE WAY HE GETS
BETTER AS NOT BEING SEEN.
THE ONLY CANDIDATE IN HISTORY
WHERE THE STRATEGY IS LESS IS
MORE.
IMAGINE WHERE ADVERTISING IS A
BAD IDEA.
RESEARCH SHOWS THE MORE PEOPLE
WHO LEARN ABOUT OUR COD LIVER
YOGURT, THE MORE PEOPLE HATE IT.
THAT IS JOE BIDEN.
THAT’S WHY HE’S IN THE BASEMENT
LIGHT GRANNY IN "EVIL DEAD 2."
IT’S IRONIC THAT WHAT’S
THREATENING THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
IS WHAT’S OFFERING IMMUNITY TO
JOB IT LIVING IN A PANDEMIC,
EVEN IF THERE IS NO PROFESSIONAL
BASEBALL, HE STILL GOING TO TRY
TO GET TO SECOND BASE.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW, GREG SAYS,
JESSE, THAT BIDEN IS BENEFITING
FROM LESS IS MORE.
TRUMP IS TRYING MORE IS MORE.
HE IS EVERYWHERE, FIRING ON ALL
CYLINDERS, DOING EVERYTHING HE
POSSIBLY CAN, TALKING TO
REPORTERS SIX TIMES TODAY.
THE CONTRAST IS STRIKING.
>> Jesse: TRUMP HAS WHAT IT
TAKES.
BIDEN JUST DOESN’T HAVE WHAT IT
HE DOESN’T BELIEVE IN HIMSELF.
IF YOU LISTEN TO HIS ANSWERS,
HE’S NOT EVEN FIGHTING FOR THE
VOTES.
HE IS LIKE, IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE
ME, VOTE FOR TRUMP.
WHAT DO I CARE?
HE USED END’S SPEECHES, YOU
KNOW, CHECK ME OUT.
IF YOU DON’T LIKE IT, VOTE FOR
THE OTHER GUY.
THERE’S NO CONFIDENCE THAT BIDEN
POSSESSES.
THAT’S BECAUSE HE KNOWS DEEP
DOWN HE’S NOT QUALIFIED TO BE
THE PRESIDENT.
HE’S NEVER BEEN A LEADER.
HE DOESN’T HAVE COMMAND OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER.
HE’S JUST NOT ARTICULATE ENOUGH
TO BE THE LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD.
WE HAVE HAD SUCH BEAUTIFULLY
ARTICULATE PRESIDENTS IN MY
ENTIRE LIFETIME.
THEY MESMERIZE YOU.
THEY BRING YOU IN.
YOU CAN’T STOP LISTENING TO THEM
TALK.
BIDEN, YOU CAN’T WAIT TILL IT’S
OVER.
HE’S GOING TO HAVE A TALL
MOUNTAIN TO CLIMB BECAUSE SOONER
OR LATER, THIS PANDEMIC IS GOING
TO END AND HE’S GOING TO HAVE TO
GET OUT THERE.
>> Dana: YEAH.
PRESIDENTS, I’VE UNDERSTOOD
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES NEED TO
SHOW FIRE IN THE BELLY.
DO WE HAVE AN AMBER IN THE BELLY
HERE IN THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN?
>> Juan: I THOUGHT HE WAS
PRETTY STRONG.
TALKING ABOUT THE TARA READE
STATEMENT.
I THINK THAT WAS A FIERY
STATEMENT, VERY CLEAR STATEMENT
THAT HE DIDN’T DO IT.
HE IS DENYING IT IN THE MOST
UNCOMPROMISING TERMS.
IF YOU THINK SHE’S TELLING THE
TRUTH, GO FOR IT.
BUT I’M TELLING YOU IT DIDN’T
HAPPEN.
HOW YOU CAN BE ANY MORE CLEAR
THAN THAT.
SO YES, I THINK THERE IS FIRE IN
THE BELLY.
I THINK HE’S BEEN STRONG ON THAT
POINT.
HE HAS DENIED IT OVER AND OVER.
THE REPORTING THAT HAS COME OUT
SINCE BOX, I SAW TODAY AT PEACE
BY PBS, NOBODY IS BACKING UP
THE CLAIM, THE ALLEGATION.
SO WE WILL SEE WHERE IT GOES.
ON THE GAFFE THING, I DON’T
THINK IT WAS BIDEN.
HANG ON.
I DON’T THINK IT WAS BIDEN WHO
SAID THAT HIS FATHER WAS BORN IN
GERMANY.
I THINK THAT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
I DON’T THINK IT WAS BIDEN WHO
SAID OH, YEAH, GEORGE WASHINGTON
CAPTURE THE AIRPORTS DURING THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR.
I THINK THAT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
SO I WONDER WHERE IS THIS COMING
FROM?
>> Dana: I WORKED FOR A
PRESIDENT THAT HAD A FEW GAFFES